we have natural tendencies that we're
better at than other things i've thought
a lot about this there's three pieces to
it there's skills beliefs and character
traits i see the ladder of success as
having three sides you have both poles
and you've got the middle handles that
you need to climb up i think that a lot
of times entrepreneurs are lopsided
their skills might be you know up to the
tenth story of the building their traits
might be to the sixth floor of the left
pole
but the handles their beliefs might be
to the third and then they're curious
and why they can't get past the third
pole and then they keep growing their
traits from the six to seven their
skills from the 10th to the 11th but
they can't get past the third thing it's
because they don't
adequately understand what their
limitation is having that level of
discernment and awareness of figuring
out what my true
bottleneck is because people solve
problems that aren't problems their
circumstances they put all this energy
and effort i need to get another
copywriting course but copywriting's not
the weak link in the chain i think
that's the piece